[Applause]
[Music]
new releases is back in the groove for
2018 and buy back in the groove I mean
throwing kamehameha's and hunting down
giant dinosaurs but of course there's a
lot more than that launching this week
so let's take a look at some of the
hottest games coming your way
Dragonball Fighters is a new fighting
game starring characters from one of the
world's most popular series developed by
the team behind guilty gear in BlazBlue
that setup really doesn't need much
explaining so I'm gonna turn it over to
new releases Canadian correspondent Matt
Padgett for his take thanks Tony
Dragon Ball Z is close to my heart and I
don't think I've ever been so excited to
play a game from just looking at it now
I'd like to call this the cuphead effect
because Dragon Ball fighters look so
much like the anime that I can hardly
believe it's something I can play and
from what I actually have played of it
man I feel like a freaking kid playing
Budokai again for the first time this
honestly feels like the perfect game for
Dragon Ball Z fans and I really hope it
carries through on that promise at
launch because if it doesn't well I'm
gonna be pretty freakin sad
thanks Matt fighters comes to ps4 Xbox
one and PC on Friday January 26 but if
you want to see the universe's best
fighters throw down before that we've
got plenty of full matches and Easter
eggs for you to check out all over
GameSpot speaking of games from reliable
developers lost fear is from the team
that brought you the 2016 darling I am
setsuna Tokyo RPG factory's next well
RPG is a spiritual successor to that
game with the same active Time battle
system and art style new to lost sphere
our mech suits that all party members
can wear both in combat and in the
overworld plus a memory restoration
system that affects the world in various
ways if that sounds up your alley then
get ready for lost spheres Western
release on ps4 PC and Nintendo switch on
Tuesday the 23rd
late January is the best time to release
a horror game right is that a thing well
maybe it will be after the impatient
makes its way to psvr if the trailer
reminds you of until dawn that's because
this scary new experience is from the
same studio and set in the same universe
it takes place 60 years before until
dawn when Blackwood sanatorium was still
open for business
you'll take control of one of the
asylums patients and the choices you
make will dramatically change your fate
you can strap in on Tuesday the 23rd if
you want something less McCobb on that
same day why not check out iconoclasts
this action platformer stars a mechanic
named Robin and you'll have to use her
handy wrench to explore the world solve
puzzles and tear down giant Robo bosses
you can ratchet up the action with
different difficulty levels two iconic
glass has been more than seven years in
the making but you can finally give it a
go on ps4 Vita and PC on the 23rd before
we close out we have to talk about the
elephant in the room or the t-rex or the
wyvern or whatever other beast you're
tracking down in Monster Hunter world
there are plenty of beasts to topple
with all 14 weapon types from the past
games but unlike previous entries the
zones here are seamless you'll be able
to party up venture out of astera
and slay your foes for more sweet armor
and weapons better than ever before
that's all coming to ps4 and Xbox one on
Friday the 26th with a PC release plan
for later this year and those are some
of the hottest games we'll be playing
this week as always remember that
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with your first batch of February
games next week